there's a really good article making the
rounds about supposed independent swing
voters and the argument is from this
article that essentially they don't
really exist and this is something I've
been talking about with you guys for
years at this point as you know if
you've been around for a while with the
show I have frequently questioned the
reality of a truly independent or
undecided voter this election especially
when we think how could someone really
be undecided between Donald Trump and
really just about anything else but even
beyond this election or beyond the world
of Trump this has been a question in
this particular case the contrasts are
so clear between Trump and anything else
that anybody who's paying any attention
and who understands what's going on it
seems almost inconceivable that there
would really be an independent swing
voter that would rationally and
carefully decide either to vote for
Donald Trump or for somebody else and
this idea of an independent swing voter
has actually almost turned into a meme
the meme of the enlightened centrist
because it makes such little sense quite
frankly and we saw some interviews on
CNN a few months ago which I played for
you with uneducated white women what I
mean by that is white women without
college education some of whom had voted
for Barack Obama and later for Donald
Trump and it was a combination as we saw
of people who were simply uninformed
about the positions of the candidates
and were sort of stumbling around and
then also some simple ignorant was a
factor as well and this gets us to
political scientists Rachel byte coffers
theory which is there is no such thing
as an actual independent swing voter
Rachel byte coffer
very accurately predicted the results of
the 2018 midterms and one of the things
that her model does is it doesn't care
about so-called independent swing voters
and in fact her theory about elections
lines up perfectly with something that
I've been screaming about to anybody who
will listen since the day Donald Trump
was elected elections are not shaped by
people who change their minds but they
are changed rather by who decides to
vote I've been
saying four years now trying to convince
Trumpets to vote for a Democrat is not a
strategy and it is a waste of time
finding people on our side and getting
them to vote is the way to go there's
this conventional wisdom which is not
always so wise that there's something
like if you have 55% turnout in the US
which is a common turnout for elections
that 15% of that 55% that chooses to
vote are so-called swing voters and they
turn the election you have to convince
those swing voters to vote for your
candidate and this assumes way more
rationality effort and consideration
than most voters are actually putting
into voting decisions it's not a
pejorative ad hominem it's just the
reality and to quote rachel bite Kaufer
she says the idea that there is this
informed engaged American population
that is watching these political events
and watching their elected leaders and
assessing their behavior and making a
judgement and it is just not true and as
she points out it's not really about
candidates swinging individual voters
from one candidate to another
it's about candidates engaging and
activating certain coalition's and
groups of voters now when other
political scientists are asked about
Rachel's theory many disagree and they
say no way there are swing voters
there's tons of people who voted for
Obama and then ultimately for Trump in
2016 or voted for Bernie in the primary
and then Trump or Hillary in the 2008
primary and what you write all these
different contingencies of people that
appear to swing from one side to the
other they exist of course anecdotally
and in small numbers but that really
what you are talking about is not a
number that swings elections what
changes in a more significant way is who
is engaged and therefore who shows up
it's not the same people switching
between Republican and Democratic
candidates that is moving elections now
if you believe Rachel Bight coffer this
suggests a totally different election
strategy and DIF
metrics for evaluating who can win the
electability question when you look at a
candidate if Rachel is correct you think
about would an imaginary regular voter
choose Trump or this candidate that's
the wrong way to think about it instead
according to Rachel's theory you would
say what effect would this can that it
have on who chooses to come out and vote
for them or against them or their
opponent for their opponent and who
chooses simply to stay home would Bernie
get more trumpets to vote for Donald
Trump that's the type of question you
ask if you believe this model instead of
the swing voter model and of course if
you believe this model the campaign
strategy shifts away from arguing with
people you don't agree with to try to
convince them to vote for your candidate
simply to finding people that are
already basically on your side and
making sure that they understand the
importance of getting out to vote and
activating voters which is exactly what
I've been saying for year for years and
this is very obvious in a very
superficial sense if you find 10 people
that generally agree with your political
view who didn't vote last time the
amount of time you would have to spend
to get a couple of them to go out and
vote is going to be far less than
finding one trumpets and arguing with
them about why they should vote for
somebody other than Trump in fact
presenting the trumpets with facts about
why their view that Trump is the right
person is completely wrong as we know
from behavioral economics is almost
guaranteed to fail and very often gets
people more sort of ingrained in their
pre-existing beliefs if you find people
that already agree with you and make it
easy for them to vote offer to help them
to vote give them some general ideas
about why it would be really important
that they go out there and vote you're
not really convincing them of much other
than saying you're allowed to vote and
you should vote and that's it
you will make way more progress that way
and that correlates so tightly with the
theory that racial bite copper is
putting forward here let me know what
you think about her article which is a
or the story about her rather in
Politico which has spread wide has been
spread very widely over the weekend let
me know what you think also about how
this relates to contingencies and
different enclaves of voters in the 2020
elections specifically one of our
sponsors today is VIN Chara watches
giving you 15% off your entire order
when you go to david pakman.com slash
watch don't pay thousands of dollars for
a high-quality watch that looks great
because you don't have to all of inch
Arrow's watches are made with high-end
materials masterfully built and they
look like something you'd spend a ton of
money on but ever even chera watch
ranges from about a hundred and fifty to
three hundred bucks I went over to their
website and picked out the bellwether
and silver and white really nice elegant
look it's a coronagraph style wore it to
a gala over the weekend and a lot of
people ask me where's the watch from
really really great look totally
different they also sent me the altitude
in matte black and red a much more
rugged view of what a watch can look
like really liked it as well as well as
the athletic strap it's a new year it's
a new decade it's time to re-establish
your style add something new to your
look and a high-quality watch is the
perfect way to do that you can get 15%
off inch arrows entire collection when
you go to david pakman.com slash watch